the world of video games is in a
constant state of flux not just the
design of the games themselves but also
how we talk about them perceive them and
enjoy them every game has a story
whether it's obvious at first or not and
that's where gamespot's new show reboot
comes in with it we're hoping to look
past the surface and make connections
see pattern to find a bigger story
beneath it all we'll be diving deeper
into the design of new games returning
to classics on their anniversaries and
dissecting the influence of older titles
on the modern industry the bottom line
is we want to look at games from new
angles and hopefully encourage you to do
the same starting this sunday februari
26 we'll be releasing a new episode
every other week but we also want your
input so on weeks when we don't publish
an episode Jake Decker and I are still
going to get together to read through
tweets and youtube comments and feature
the best ones on our show tell us what
you like tell us what you didn't like
suggest episodes in the future we want
to start a conversation we can't do that
without you our first episode releases
Sunday februari 26 focus is on silent
Hills and resident evil 7 few vastly
different games that are more closely
related than you might think we'll see
that
[Music]
[Applause]
you